hi there welcome to this video I'm
Samuel and I'm very glad that you're
watching this video here we're gonna
talk about Amazon ECS a service that's
used to manage docker containers so
without any further ado let's get
started
in this session we would like to talk
about some basics about AWS and then
we're gonna immediately dive into why
Amazon ECS and what is Amazon ECS in
general and then it uses a service
called docker so we're gonna understand
what docker is and there are competitive
services available for ECS I mean you
could easiest is not the own and only
service to manage docker containers but
why UCS advantage of easiest we will
talk about that and the architecture of
easiest so how it functions what are the
components present in it and what are
the functions that it does I mean each
and every component what are all the
functions that it does all those things
will be discussed in the architecture of
Amazon ECS and how it works how it all
connects together that's something we
will discuss and what are the companies
that are using easiest what were the
challenge and how easy has helped to fix
the challenge that's something we will
discuss and finally we have a wonderful
lab that talks about how to deploy
docker containers on an Amazon ECS so
let's talk about what is AWS Amazon Web
service in short called as AWS is an web
servers in the cloud that provides a
variety of services such as compute
power database storage content delivery
and a lot of other resources so you can
scale your business and grow not focus
more on your IT needs and the rest of
the ID demands rather you can focus on
your business and let Amazon scale your
IT or let Amazon take care of your IT so
what is that you can do with AWS with
AWS we can create deploy any
Legation in the cloud so it's not just
deploying you can also create your
application in the cloud it has all the
tools and services required the tools
and services that you would have
installed in your laptop or you would
have installed in your on-premises
desktop machine for your development
environment you know the same thing can
be installed and used from the cloud so
you can used cloud for creating and not
only that you can use the same cloud for
deploying and making your application
available for your end-user the end user
could be internal internal users the end
user could be it could be in the
Internet the end user could be kind of
spread all around the world it doesn't
matter so it can be used to create and
deploy your applications in the cloud
and like you might have guessed it
provides service over the Internet
that's how your users worldwide would be
able to use the service that you create
and deploy right so it provides service
over the Internet
so that's for the end customer and how
will you access those services that's
again through the internet it's like the
extension of your data center in the
internet so it provides all the services
in the internet it provides compute
service through the internet so in other
words you access them through the
internet it provides database service
through the internet over the Internet
in other words you can securely access
your database through the internet and
lot more and the best part is this is a
pay-as-you-go or pay only for what you
use there is no long term or you know
beforehand commitment here most of the
services does not have any commitment so
there is no long term and before hand
commitment you only pay exactly for what
you use there's no overage there's no
old pain right there's no buying in
advance right you only pay for what you
use let's talk about what
ECS is so before easiest before
containers right easiest is a service
that manages docker containers right
it's not a product or it's not a feature
all by itself it's a service that's
dependent on docker container so before
docker containers all the applications
were running on VM or on an host or on
an physical machine right and that's
memory bound
that's latency bound the server might
have issues on and on right so let's say
this is Alice and she's trying to access
her application which is running
somewhere in her on premises and the
application isn't working what could be
the reason some of the reasons could be
memory for the server's currently down
at the moment we don't have another
physical server to launch the
application a lot of other reasons so a
lot of reasons why the application
wouldn't be working in on-premises some
of them are memory full issue and server
down issue very less a high availability
or in fact single point of failure and
no high availability if I if I need to
tell it correctly with easiest the
services can kind of breed free right
the services can run seamlessly now how
how is that possible the DOS thing we
will discuss in the upcoming sessions so
because of containers and easiest
managing containers the applications can
run in a high available mode they can
run in an high available mode meaning if
something goes wrong right there's
another container that gets fund up and
your application runs in that particular
container very less chances of your
application going down that's what I
mean this is not possible with a
physical a host this is very less
possible with an VM or at least it's
gonna take some time for another VM to
get spun up so YEC is or what is easiest
Amazon easiest maintains the
availability of the application and
allows every user to scale containers
when necessary so it not only meets the
availability of the application meaning
one container running your application
or one container hosting your
application should be running all the
time so me that high availability
availability is making sure your service
is running 24/7 so container makes sure
that your services run 24/7 not only
there
not only that suddenly if there is an
increase in demand how do you meet that
demand right let's say you have like
thousand users suddenly the next week
there are like two thousand users all
right so how do you meet that demand
container makes it very easy for you to
meet that demand in case of VM or in
case of physical host you literally will
have to go buy another physical host or
add more RAM add more memory add more
CPU power to it right our kind of Club
to three hosts together clustering you
would be doing a lot of other things to
meet that the high availability and also
to meet that demand but in case of ecs
it automatically scales the number of
containers it automatically scales the
number of containers needed and it meets
your demand for that particular R so
what is Amazon easiest the full form of
e CS is elastic container service right
so it's basically a container management
service which can quickly launch and
exit and manage docker containers on a
cluster so what's the function of e CS
it helps us to quickly launch and
quickly exit and manage docker container
so it's kind of a management service for
the docker containers you will be
running in Amazon or running in the AWS
environment so in addition to that it
helps to schedule the placement of
container across your cluster so it's
like this you have two physical hosts
you know join together as a cluster and
easiest helps us to place your
containers know where should your
container be placed shouldn't be placed
in oast one should be placed in host two
so that logic is defined in ECS we can
define it you can also let ECS take
control and define that logic most cases
you will be defining it so schedule the
placement of containers across your
cluster let's say two containers wanna
interact heavily you really don't want
to place them in two different hosts
alright you would want to place them in
one single horse so they can interact
with each other so that logic is defined
by us
and these container services you can
launch containers using AWS management
console and also you can launch
containers using SDK kids available from
Amazon you can launch through a Java
program you can launch container using
an darkman program you can launch
container using an node.js program as an
when the situation demands so there are
multiple ways you can launch containers
through management console and also
programmatically and ECS also helps to
migrate application to the cloud without
changing the code so anytime you think
of migration the first thing that comes
to your mind is that how will that
environment be based on that I'll have
to alter my code what's what's the IP
what is the storage that's been used
what what are the different parameters
I'll have to include the environment
parameters of the new environment with
containers you know that worry is
already taken away because we can create
and pretty exact environment the one
that you had an on-premises the same
environment gets created in the cloud so
no worries about changing the
application parameter
no worries about changing the code in
the application you can be like if it
ran in my laptop a container that I was
running in my laptop it's definitely
gonna run in the cloud as well because
I'm gonna use the same container in the
laptop and also in the cloud in fact
you're gonna ship it you're gonna move
the container from your laptop to Amazon
ECS and make it run there so it's like
the same the very same image the very
same container that was running in your
laptop will be running in the cloud or
production environment so what is docker
we know that it ECS helps to quickly
launch exit and manage docker containers
what is stalker let's let's answer that
question what is docker now docker is a
tool that helps to automate the
development of an application as a
lightweight container so that the
application can work efficiently in
different environments this is pretty
much what we discussed right before the
slide I can
build an application in my laptop or in
on-premises in a container environment
docker container environment and anytime
I want to migrate right I don't have to
kind of rewrite the core and then rerun
the core in that new environment I can
simply create an image a docker image
and move that image to that production
or the new cloud environment and simply
launch it there right so no compiling
again no relaunching the application
simply pack all your code in a docker
container image and ship it to the new
environment and launch the container
there that's all so docker container is
a light-weight package of software that
contains all the dependencies so because
you know when packing you'll be packing
all the dependencies you'll be packing
the code you'll be packing the framework
you'll be packing the libraries that are
required to run the application so in
the new environment you can be pretty
sure you can't be guaranteed that it's
gonna run because it's the very same
code it's a very same framework it's the
very same libraries that you have
shipped right there's nothing new in
that new environment it's the very same
thing that's gonna run in that container
so it can be rest assured that they are
gonna run in that new environment and
these docker containers are highly
scalable and they are very efficient
suddenly you wanted like 20 more docker
containers to run the application think
of adding 20 more hosts to any more VMs
right how much time would it take and
compact at that time the amount of time
that docker containers would require to
kind of scale to that amount like 20
more containers it's very less or it's
minimal or negligible so it's an highly
scalable and it's a very efficient
service you can suddenly scale number of
docker containers to meet any additional
demand very short boot up time because
it takes it's not going to load the
whole operating system and these docker
containers you know they use the Linux
kernel and features of the kernel like C
groups and namespaces to kind of
segregate the processor so they can run
in
any environment and it takes very less
time to boot up and in the data's that
are stored in the containers are kind of
reusable so you can have an external
data volume and I can map it to the
Container and whatever the space that's
occupied by the container and the data
is that the container puts in that
volume they are kind of reusable you can
simply map it to another application you
can kind of remap it to the next
successive container you can kind of
remap it to the next version of the
container next version of the
application you'll be launching and you
don't have to go through building the
data again from the scratch whatever
data the container was using previously
or the previous container was using that
data is available for the next container
as well so the volumes that the
containers users are very reusable
volumes and like I said it's isolated
application so it kind of isolates by
its nature it kind of by the way it's
designed by the way it is created it
isolates one container from another
container meaning any time you run
applications on different containers you
can be rest assured that they are very
much isolated though they are running on
the same host though they are running on
the same laptop let's say though they
are running on the same physical machine
let's say running ten containers ten
different applications it can be sure
that they are well disconnected or well
isolated applications now let's talk
about the advantages of ECS the
advantage of ecs is improved security
its security is inbuilt in ECS with ecs
we have something called as a container
registry you know that's where all your
images are stored and those images are
accessed only through HTTPS not only
that those images are actually encrypted
and access to those images are allowed
and denied through identity and access
management policies I am and in other
words let's say two container running on
the same instance the one container can
have access to s3 and the others or the
rest of the others are denied access to
s3
that kind of granular security can be
achieved through containers when we mix
and match the other security products
available in Amazon like I am encryption
accessing it using HTTPS these
containers are very cost efficient like
I already said these are lightweight
processes we can schedule multiple
containers on the same node and this
actually allows us to achieve high
density on an ec2 instance imagine an
ec2 instance that that's very less
utilized that's not possible with a
container because you can actually dense
or crowd and ec2 instance with more
container in it so to best use those
resources in ec2 straightforward you can
just launch one application but with
when we use containers you can launch
like 10 different applications on the
same ec2 server that means 10 different
applications can actually feed on those
resources available and can benefit the
application and easiest not only deploys
the container it also maintains the
state of the containers and it makes
sure that the minimum a set of
containers are always running based on
the requirement that's another cost
efficient way of using it right and
anytime an application fails and that
has a direct impact on the revenue of
the company and easiest to make sure
that you're not losing any revenue
because your application has failed and
easiest is and pretty extensible
services it's like this in many
organization there are a majority of
unplanned work because of environment
variation a lot of fire fighting happens
when we kind of deployed the cord from
one or kind of move the cord or redeploy
the cord in a new environment lot of
fire fighting happens there right this
docker containers are pretty extensible
like we discussed already
environment is not a concern for
containers because it's gonna kind of
shut itself inside a docker container
and anywhere the docker container can't
run the application will run exactly the
way it performed in the past so
environment is not a concern for the
docker
in addition to that ECS is easily
scalable we have discussed this already
and it improves it has improved
compatibility we have discussed this
already let's talk about the
architecture of ECS like you know now
the architecture of ECS is the easiest
cluster itself that's group of servers
running the ECS service and it
integrates with the docker right so we
have a docker registry docker registry
is a repository where we store all the
docker images or the container images so
it's like three components easiest is of
three components one is the easiest
cluster itself when I say easy as itself
I'm referring to easiest cluster cluster
of servers that will run the containers
and then the repository where the images
will be stored right the repository
where the images will be stored and the
image itself so container images the
template of instructions which is used
to create a container right so it's like
what's the OS what is the version of
node that should be running and any
additional software do we need so those
question gets answered here so it's the
template template of instructions which
is used to create the containers and
then the registry is the service where
the docker images are stored and shared
so many people can store there and many
people can access or if there's another
group that wants to access they can
access the image from there or one
person can store the image and rest of
the team can access them the rest of the
team can store imagine this one person
can pick the image from there and kind
of ship it to the customer or ship it to
the production environment all that's
possible in this container registry an
Amazon's version of the container
registry is ECR and there's a
third-party docker itself has a
container registry that's docker hub ECS
itself which is the the group of servers
that runs those containers so these two
the container image and the continent
registry they can have handle docker in
an image format just an image format and
in
this is where the container gets live
and then it becomes an compute orso's
and starts to handle requests now starts
to serve the page and starts to the
batch job you know whatever your plan is
with that container so the cluster of
servers
ECS integrates well with familiar
services like V PC
V PC is known for securing V PC is known
for isolating the whole environment from
rest of the customers or isolating the
whole environment or the whole
infrastructure from the rest of the
clients in your account or from the rest
of the applications in your account on
and on so any pcs the service that
provides or gives you the network
isolation easiest integrates well with V
PC and this V PC enables us to launch
AWS resources such as Amazon ec2
instance in a virtual private network
that we specified this is basically what
we just discussed now let's take a
closer look at the easiest how does
easiest work let's find answer for this
question how does easiest work easiest
has got a couple of components within
itself
so these easiest servers can run across
availability zone as you can see there
are two availability zones here they can
actually run across availability zones
and easiest has got two modes Fargate
mode and the easy do more but here we
seen forget mode and then here we're
seeing nothing that means it's an ec2
more and then it has got different
network interfaces attached to it
because they need to be running in an
isolated fashion right so anytime you
want network isolation you need separate
IP and if you want separate IP you need
separate network interface card and
that's what you have elastic network
interface card separate elastic network
interface card for all those tasks and
services and this runs within an V PC
let's talk about the Fargate service
tasks are launched using the Fargate
service so we will discuss about task
what is forget now forget is a compute
engine and easiest that allows users to
lon
containers without having to monitor the
cluster easiest is a service that
manages the containers for you right
otherwise managing containers will be an
Fulton job so easy earth manages it for
you and if you and you get to manage
easiest that's the basic service but if
you want Amazon to manage GCS and the
containers for you we can go for forget
so forget is a compute engine in ECS
that allows users to launch containers
without having to monitor the easiest
cluster and the tasks the tasks that we
discussed the tasks has two components
you see tasks right here so they have
two components we have easiest container
instance and then the container agent so
like you might have guessed right now
easiest container instance is actually
easy to instance or a capable of running
containers not all ec2 instances can run
container
so these are like specific ec2 instances
that can run containers they are ECS
container instances and then we have
container agent which is the agent that
actually binds those clusters together
and it does a lot of other housekeeping
work right kind of connects clusters
makes sure that the version needed is
present so it's all part of that agent
or it's all job of that agent container
instances container instances is part of
Amazon ec2 instance which run Amazon ECS
container agent pretty straightforward
definition and then a container agent is
responsible for communication between
ECS and the instance and it also
provides the status of the running
containers kind of monitors the
container monitors the state of the
container make sure that the container
is up and running and if there's
anything wrong it kind of reports it to
the appropriate service to fix the
container on and on it's a container
agent when we don't manage container
agent it runs by itself and you really
don't have to do anything to make the
container agent better it's already
better you really won't be configuring
anything in the agent and then elastic
network interface card is and virtual
interface network that can be connected
to an instance in V PC so in other words
elastic network interface is how the
container interacts with another
container and that's how the container
in trucks with the ec2 hosts and that's
how the container interacts with the
internet external world and a cluster a
cluster is a set of easiest container
instances it's not something that's very
difficult to understand it's simply a
group of ec2 instances that runs that
ECS agent and this cluster cluster
handles the process of scheduling
monitoring and scaling the request we
know that easiest
can scale the containers can scale how
does it scale that's all monitor and
managed by this easiest cluster let's
talk about the companies that are using
Amazon SES there are a variety of
companies that use easiest clusters to
name a few
okhta users easiest cluster and okhta is
a product that use identity information
to grant people access to applications
on multiple devices at any given point
of trying to make sure that they have a
very strong security protection so okhta
uses Amazon ECS to run their okhta
application and serve their customers
and a beamer a beamer is an a TV channel
and they chose to use micro services and
a docker containers they already had
micro services and docker containers and
when they thought about a service that
they can use in AWS ECS was the only
service that they can immediately adapt
to and because in a beamer TVD engineers
have already been using docker and
docker containers it was kind of easy
for them to adapt themselves to ECS and
start using it along with the benefits
that ECS provides previously they had to
do lot of work but now easiest does it
for them or it similarly remind and
Ubisoft go
or some of the famous companies that use
Amazon ECS and get benefitted from its
scalability get benefited from its cost
gets benefited from its Amazon managed
services get benefited from the
portability that ECS and the migration
option that easiest provides let's talk
about how to deploy a docker container
on Amazon ACS the way to deploy docker
container on EC is this first we need to
have an AWS account and then setup and
run our first ECS cluster so in our lab
we're going to use the launch wizard to
run and ECS cluster and run containers
in them and then toss definition toss
definition tells the size of the
container the number of the container
and when we talk about size it tells how
much your CPU do you need how much of
memory do you need and talking about
numbers you know it requires how many
numbers of container you're gonna launch
you know is it 5 is it 10 or is it just
one running all the time
now those kind of information goes in
the task definition file and then we can
do some advanced configuration on ECS
like a load balancers and you know what
port number you want to allow and you
don't want to allow you know who gets
access who shouldn't get access and
what's the IP that you want to allow and
deny a request from on and on and this
is where we would also mention the name
of the containers or a differentiate one
container from the other and the name of
the service now is it end in a backup
job is it web application is it end data
container is it gonna take care of your
data data back-end and the desired
number of tasks that you want to be
running all the time those details go in
when we try to configure the ECS service
all right and then you configure cluster
you put in all the security in the
configure your cluster step or configure
cluster stage and finally we will have
an instance and a bunch of containers
running in that instance alright let's
do a demo so here I have logged in to my
Amazon portal and let me switch to the
appropriate region
I'm gonna pick not Virginia not Virginia
look for ECS and it tells easiest is a
service that helps to run and manage
docker containers well and good click on
it
I'm a not Virginia I just want to make
sure that I'm in the right region and go
to clusters and here we can create
cluster this is our far gate and this is
our easy to type launching for Linux and
Windows environment but I'm going to
launch through this walk through portal
right this gives a lot of information
here so the different steps involved
here is creating a container definition
which is what we're gonna do right now
and then a task definition and then
service and finally the cluster it's a
four step process so in container
definition we define the image the base
image we are going to use now here I'm
gonna launch and httpd or a simple head
cdb web page alright so as simple hits
DBD 2.4 image is fair enough for me and
it's not that heavy application so 0.5
gigabit of memory is enough and again
it's not a heavy application so 0.25
virtual CPU is enough in our case all
right you can edit it based on the
requirement you can always edit it and
because I'm using HD PD the port mapping
is already port 80 that's how the
container is gonna receive the request
and there's no health check as if now
when we want a design critical and
complicated environments we can include
health check right and this is the CPU
that we have chose we can edit it and
I'm gonna use some bash commands to
create an HTML page this page says that
you know Amazon easiest sample app right
and then it says Amazon easy a sample
app your application is running on a
container in Amazon ECS so that's the
page the HTML page that I'm gonna create
index dot HTML I'm going to create and
put it in an appropriate location so
those pages can be served from the
container right if you replace this with
any
your own content then it's gonna be your
own content easiest comes with some
basic logs and these are the places
where they get stored that's not the
focus as of now all right so are you
saying that you can't edit it and
customize it to your needs we're not
gonna do any customization now we're
just getting familiar with easiest now
and the task definition name of the task
definition is first one task definition
and then we are running it in a V PC and
then this is an Fargate mode meaning the
servers are completely handled by Amazon
and the task memory is 0.5 gigabit and
the task view is point two five virtual
CPU name of the service is it a batch
job is it and you know front-end is it
and back-end or is it a simple copy job
what's the service name of the service
goes here again this you can edit it and
here's a security group as of now I'm
allowing for 82 the whole world if I
want to restrict to a certain IP I can
do that the default option for load
balancing is no load balancer but I can
also choose to have a load balancer and
use port 80 to map that port 80 to the
container port 80 right I can do that
the default is no load balancer all
right let's do one thing let's use load
balancer let's use load balancer and
port 80 as it receives information on
port 80 HTTP oh what's gonna be the
cluster name where in the last step
what is the cluster name cluster name
can be simply long you see as demo next
we're done and we can create so it's
launching a cluster as you can see and
it's picking the task definition file
that we've created and it's using that
to launch and service and then these are
the log groups that we discussed and
it's creating your V PC remember easy as
clubs well with the V PC it's creating a
V PC and it's creating two subnets here
for high availability it's creating that
security group port 80 allowed to the
whole world and then it's putting it
behind and load balancer it generally
would take like five to ten minutes
so we just need to be patient and let it
complete its creation and once this is
completed we can simply access these
servers using the load balancer URL and
when this is running and let me actually
take you to the other products or the
other services that are integrated with
ECS it's getting created our service is
getting created as of now ECR repository
this is where all our images are stored
now as of now I'm not pulling my image
from ECR I'm pulling it directly from
the internet docker docker hub but all
custom images all custom images they are
stored in this repository so you can
create a repository call it have one
created repository so here's my
repository so any image that I create
locally or any docker image that I
create locally I can actually push them
push those images using these commands
right here and they get stored here and
I can make my easiest connect to with
ECR and pull images from here so there
would be my custom images and as of now
because I'm using a default image it's
directly pulling it from the Internet
let's go to ec2 and look for a load
balancer because we wanted to access the
application from behind a load balancer
right so here is a load balancer created
for us and anytime I put the URL so
cluster is now created you see there's
one service running all right let's
click on that
cluster here is the name of our
application and here is the tasks to
different containers that we are running
and if we click on it we have an IP
right IP of that container and it says
it's running it was created at
such-and-such time and started at
such-and-such time and this is the task
definition file that it this container
users meaning the template the details
to all the version details they all come
from here and it belongs to the cluster
called simply loan
ECS demo right and you can also get some
logs kind
logs from here so let's go back and
there are no easiest instances here
because remember this is forget you're
not managing any easiest instance right
so that's why you're not seeing any
easiest instance here so let's go back
to task and go back to the same page
where we found the IP pick that IP put
it in the browser and he have this
sample HTML page running from an
container so let me go back to load
balancer you see - and then under ec2
I'll be able to find a load balancer
find that load balancer pick that DNS
name put it in the browser
and now it's accessible to the load
balancer URL right now this URL can be
mapped to other services like DNS this
URL can be embroidered in any of your
application if you want to make that
application connect with this container
now using IP is not all that advisable
because these containers can die and
then a new container gets created and
when a new container gets created it
gets a new IP right so a hot coding IP
is not hard coding dynamic IPS or not
advisable so you would be using load
balancer and putting that URL in that
application that you want to make it
interact with this container instance it
was a wonderful experience and walking
you through this easiest stop again and
here we learn about what AWS is and why
we using ECS and what is easiest in
general what is docker in specific and
we also learn about the advantages of
ecs the architecture the different
components of ECS and how easiest works
when they are all connected together and
we also looked at the companies that use
e CS and their use cases and finally our
lab how we can launch CCS Fargate
through the portal that's all I had for
today I believe you enjoyed the session
please stay tuned for more videos like
this thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here